BRET BAIER.
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON, I’M
BRET BAIER.
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO MINIMIZE
THE SELF-INFLICTED DAMAGE FROM
COMMENTS VIEWED AS ANTI-SEMITIC
FROM ONE OF THEIR HIGH PROFILE
FRESHMEN LAWMAKERS, WE ARE ALSO
AWAITING THE SENTENCING OF
FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN
PAUL MANAFORT.
FIRST, DEMOCRATS AND
ANTI-SEMITISM, WHAT WAS ONCE
THOUGHT TO BE AN EASY FIX, A
PUBLIC RESOLUTION HAS TURNED
INTO A POLITICAL FOOTBALL AND
REPUBLICANS AND EVEN SOME
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING THE
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP IN THE
HOUSE IS FUMBLING THAT FOOTBALL.
MIKE EMANUEL STARTS US OFF
TONIGHT WITH CAPITOL HILL WITH A
VOTE THAT JUST WRAPPED UP.
>> 400-23, IOWA STEVE KING
KING VOTING PRESENT.
NANCY PELOSI IS FORCED TO DEFEND
ONE OF HER HIGH PROFILE FRESHMAN
MEMBERS.
>> I DO NOT BELIEVE SHE
UNDERSTOOD THE FULL WEIGHT OF
THE WORDS.
>> A REFERENCE TO MINNESOTA
DEMOCRAT CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN
OMAR WHO SUGGESTED THOSE WHO
SUPPORT ISRAEL HAVE A DUAL
LOYALTY, THAT BEING OPPOSED TO
PRIME MINISTER
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU AND THE
OCCUPATION IS NOT THE SAME AS
BEING ANTI-SEMITIC.
THE ANTI-SEMITIC RESOLUTION
NOTED THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES CONDEMNS
ANTI-SEMITIC ACTS THAT ARE
CONTRADICTORY TO THE VALUES OF
THE PEOPLE THAT DEFINED THE
PEOPLE OF THE UNITED STATES.
AFTER AN INTERNAL BATTLE, THE
NAME OF THE RESOLUTION WAS
CHANGED TO ANTI-HATE AND WAS
BROADENED TO INCLUDE A WIDE
RANGE OF BIGOTRY VICTIMS.
, MUSLIMS, HINDUS, THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY, IMMIGRANTS, AND
OTHERS WITH VERBAL ATTACKS,
INCITEMENT, AND VIOLENCE.
>> WE ARE SEEING A RISE IN
ANTI-SEMITISM, A RISE IN
ISLAMOPHOBIA, A RISE IN RACISM
AND BIGOTRY.
>> NEW YORK DEMOCRAT ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS BEEN TWEETING
TO HER NEARLY THREE AND A HALF
MILLION FOLLOWERS, THERE SEEMS
TO BE NO PROBLEM AT ALL WITH A
ZERO TOLERANCE STANCE FOR SIMPLY
ASKING ABOUT U.S. FOREIGN POLICY
ASKING ABOUT U.S. FOREIGN POLICYAND MICHIGAN DEMOCRAT SHE DID TO
AND MICHIGAN DEMOCRAT SHE DID TOLEAVE
LEAVE
WENT FURTHER.
>> WHAT I HEAR IS HER TRYING TO
UPLIFT MY GRANDMOTHER IN
PALESTINE AND THE WEST BANK,
THERE ARE ACTUAL, FACTUAL
EVIDENCE TO SHOW THERE ARE HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS.
>> REPUBLICANS SOUNDED STUNNED.
>> THERE’S A FRACTURE OBVIOUSLY,
A RADICAL LEFTIST FRINGE THAT IS
INTOLERANT.
>> ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES INVOKES
THE CLASSIC ANTI-SEMITIC
LANGUAGE THAT CONTROL THE WORLD,
CARE ONLY ABOUT MONEY, CANNOT BE
LOYAL AMERICANS IF THEY ALSO
SUPPORT ISRAEL, THIS MUST BE
CONDEMNED.
>> REPUBLICANS SAY THE SHIFT TO
THE LEFT IS SHOCKING.
>> THIS IS NOT YOUR FATHER’S
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I DON’T KNOW WHEN IT WAS MORE
OBVIOUS.
THEY CAN’T AGREE TO CONDEMN
ANTI-SEMITISM.
>> SOME SOURCES SUGGEST THIS
SIGNALS POSSIBLE TROUBLE FOR
NANCY PELOSI AND HER LEADERSHIP